but you know one person who doesn't ever
learn from their mistakes
jared kushner
according to a new report
from the new york times it turns out
that jared kushner was in fact the
individual who gave the green light to
alex holder's documentary crew
to come along and film the trump family
starting in september 2020
and of course as everybody now knows
this is the documentary footage that has
been
given over the raw footage
given over to the january six committee
they're actually you know meeting with
mr holder today behind closed doors he's
testifying he's going through footage
with them
they're having a grand old time
but we don't know
exactly what's in this footage except of
course
for a little snippet that the new york
times gave us again
jared kushner set this up
because he thought it would be a good
quote legacy project
for the trump campaign of the trump
family
and based on the tiny bit of footage
that has been viewed
by the media
we know that ivanka trump
told the documentary crew
that she actually supported
her father's efforts
to overturn the election
now that's a bit of a different story
isn't it
because from everything we have seen
from her text messages with mark meadows
from her testimony in front of the
january 6 committee she didn't want
anything to do with this
she wanted this to be over
i mean heck her and jared actually threw
a party on the evening of january 7th
the day after the capitol riot through a
big old dinner party
where according to reports nobody even
brought up what happened the day before
yeah she washed her hands of it acted
like nope i was never a part of it never
wanted anything to do with it never
supported it bill barr and i had
conversations where we talked about yeah
this whole thing is stupid it didn't
happen trump even came out recently
attacked bill barr for allegedly
corrupting ivanka because she was afraid
of hurting his feelings so she just
agreed with him
that the election wasn't stolen
and now it turns out that he may have
been right
because according to this footage again
it's been viewed by the new york times
ivanka came out in an interview with
this documentary crew from alex holder
and agreed with the attempts to overturn
the 2020 election
now again
she told the january 6 committee a
different story
and she testified to that under oath
so
yikes right
hmm
almost almost seems
not saying it is but i'm saying it seems
to me
like that may be a little bit of perjury
right
you you can't say one thing under oath
but then
say something else one of those things
is a lie
and if what you told congress is a lie
then uh-oh
you may have some serious legal problems
on your hands there ivanka
but of course all the committee could
really do at that point is issue a
criminal referral if they choose to go
that route right i mean they may even
look at it and say
we'll just point it out to the public
how she's a big old liar and a hypocrite
and move on which
at this point you know who knows what
could happen because we don't know what
else is in that footage
but that's what we do know so far
it's a tiny little snippet a tiny little
piece
of probably thousands of hours of
footage
and so far it looks pretty bad for the
trump family one of our sponsors is
early the delicious crunchy crackers
that are fighting climate change did you
know over 25 percent of greenhouse gases
come from the global
food supply chain a lot of companies
talk about getting to net zero carbon
emissions by 2030 or whatever date airli
has been net zero since day one and they
will never be a net carbon emitter each
box of airly crackers removes 18 to 21
grams of co2 from the air that's why
it's called airlie they're available in
four delicious sweeter savory flavors
cheddar sea salt chocolate salted
caramel or caramel as some people like
to say whole grain oats are always the
main ingredient they're made with 100
real cheese cocoa butter brown sugar our
whole team loves them i know you will
too it is a snack you can feel good
about go to early foods dot com slash
pacman and use the code pacman for 25
off the link is down below